[Música]
el senado de eeuu continúa la
investigación por el asalto al capitolio
el pasado 6 de enero donde perdieron la
vida cinco personas luego de que
seguidores del expresidente de donald
trump irrumpieron violentamente en el
legislativo estadounidense este barón
aliado del ex presidente de eeuu donald
trump se entregó este lunes tras haber
sido imputado por desacato al no
responder a una situación del comité
legislativo que investiga este asalto
barón fue liberado por una orden de una
jueza pero sin su pasaporte para evitar
así que salga de eeuu en los últimos
días un tribunal impidió revelar pidió
revelar temporalmente más de 770 páginas
de documentos del gobierno son sobre
este asalto asalto para ello quiero
saludar en este momento de nuestro
segundo invitado el día el ese ser paz
agente retirado del fbi y también
consultor en seguridad gracias a césar
por estar con nosotros en directo a
américa le pregunta entonces que ocurren
con esta investigación de la toma del
capital estadounidense
buenos días en primer lugar muchísimas
gracias por la invitación en cuanto a la
investigación la investigación se ha
efectuado pero
lamentablemente el problema que yo veo
desde el punto de vista de seguridad es
que los poderes políticos se han
apoderado de este tema y están tratando
de
cada por cada uno por su lado de
triunfar con sus ideologías políticas y
de prevalecer ante el público el
problema que veo en cuanto al señor
bernal es que en primer lugar él puede
ejercer si es que preside ex presidente
de donald trump lo desea así puede ser
lo que se conoce como el
privilegio ejecutivo este privilegio de
cultivo le da cualquier siguiente a
cualquier
testigo
el derecho de poder guardar cierta
documentación mensajes etcétera
completamente secretos
y no lo hacen porque necesariamente hay
algo indebido malo o criminal en
naturaleza no lo hace porque en muchas
ocasiones pueden revelar fuentes de
información o ciertos métodos que han
utilizado para obtener esa información
el desacato es un crimen menor
no creo que el departamento de justicia
vaya a proseguir con algún tipo de
enjuiciamiento en contra el señor barón
porque esta tradición viene desde 1935
en la administración del señor obama
hubo varios testigos
no fueron imputados porque no fueron
llevados a juicio ahora césar el
expresidente donald trump ya logró
impedir que estos documentos entonces no
lleguen al senado que incidencias va a
tener esta decisión en esta
investigación realmente si se va a saber
la verdad de lo que ocurrió y qué tanto
quiere esconder el expresidente donald
trump porque tal de insistencia por
impedir que se conozca la verdad de lo
ocurrido el pasado 6 de enero pero la
verdad de lo ocurrido está a la vista de
todos los televidentes a la vista de
todo el público y me permite explicarlo
en pocos segundos
lamentablemente la prensa amarillista
aquí en este país es quien eeuu está
completamente desubicado por lo tanto lo
que lo que yo he hecho al analizar este
tema al ver horas de horas y horas de
vídeos de declaraciones etcétera
etcétera lo que yo recomiendo es que las
personas traten de analizar de dónde ver
no solamente un vídeo de una sola fuente
de información sino de varias fuentes de
información y poder lograr o llegar a
algún tipo de
de opinión que es lo que quiere esconder
todo lo mencioné hace poco hace pocos
segundos es probablemente métodos o
algún tipo de información que vino de
fuentes que no quieren revelar no
necesariamente que están escondiendo
algo criminal en el naturaleza ya
sabemos y lamentablemente esto no
sería un poquito no ya sabemos lo que
pasó durante el plazo la administración
de trauma entonces quiero que quieren
ahora el partido opuesto porque quiere
prevalecer ahora van o no puede salir de
eeuu pero al final él si va a responder
o va a decir
su versión de lo que ocurrió el 6 de
enero qué va a pasar con este caso varón
una pieza clave en esta investigación
pero el señor barón se retire el
pasaporte documentos de viajes de
cualquier persona que está
imputada eso es algo irregular y son lo
común y sucede eso no es nada irregular
los que han pedido el no se va a ir del
país obviamente es una persona que vive
aquí
la declaración que puede dar que tiene
el derecho de negarse a dar también
es eso va a basarse en la decisión que
él y su abogado
tomen pero en realidad lo que yo sugiero
es que las personas para formarse un
mejor criterio de esto vean no solamente
una fuente de información sino todas las
fuentes de información y aparte de eso
también aquellos que
llevan blogs
públicos donde se exponen realmente lo
que sí sucedió durante enero 6 ahora se
requiere preguntar entonces cómo va a
incidir esta investigación de cara a las
elecciones de medio término 2022 cómo
llegan estas dos grandes fuerzas
políticas en eeuu habló por supuesto los
republicanos y también de los demócratas
bien yo que pienso desde mi punto de
vista nada más pienso que el pueblo
americano se ha dado cuenta de la serie
de errores que esta nueva administración
ha cometido no no es que soy partidista
en este momento pero como usuario común
al acercarme a una bomba de gasolina o
una estación de gasolina y tener que
pagar dos o tres veces el precio de la
gasolina que pagaba antes antes de enero
entonces duele en el bolsillo cuando
tengo que no restaurante y la comida los
servicios han subido al doble duele en
el bolsillo yo creo que el público se va
a dar cuenta no solamente de la
inflación de la cual sufre este país y
eso es lo que va a llevar a que ellos
gocen de una manera u otra usted como
agente reiterado el fbi también
consultor en seguridad cree que ese 6 de
enero ya para finalizar esta
conversación es césar hubo fallas en la
seguridad del capitolio
hubo muchas fallas en primer lugar yo
pienso de todas las horas que me he
dedicado a ver y una vez más yo soy
partidista ok pero lo que yo pienso es
que seguridad salió y pienso también que
personas que participaron dentro de la
policía del capitolio son de sharp se
han aliado al partido político
demócrata y han expuesto sus criterios
que realmente no son que son solamente
unilaterales de lo que ha sucedido no
pienso yo que fue dictado por la
administración presión al trabajo por
chang yo pienso que hubo grupos de
intereses que se aprovecharon de esa
oportunidad y ejecutaron ciertos hechos
que son no solamente criminales pero es
una violación a la integridad del
capitolio y del pueblo americano